hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead today
i'm going to explain a mystery and
science fiction movie called mirage
in 1989 during the fall of the berlin
wall and a 72-hour long electrical storm
there is a boy named nico who likes
playing a guitar
while he is recording himself playing
the guitar he hears some noises and sees
a fight scene in his neighbor's house
through a window
nico who is curious about it immediately
sneaks into his neighbor's house to see
what happened
when he goes inside he is very surprised
because he sees mrs weiss was dead
shortly after prieto who is the husband
of mrs weiss comes down with a knife in
his hand
seeing prieto with a knife nico tries to
escape unfortunately he is accidentally
hit by a car on the road
nico's friend outdoor sees him dies in
the car accident as prieto is arrested
with the murder weapon in his hand
in 2014 eitore who has grown up and
works as a pilot still lives in the
residential area with his mother clara
as they look up at the sky an agitated
clara tells itour that this electrical
storm is similar as the storm that
occurred 25 years ago during nico's
death
meanwhile a married couple veera and
david move into nico's old house along
with their daughter gloria
unintentionally they find an old tv in a
storeroom along with a video recorder
and cassettes
they decide to watch one of the
cassettes which contains a recording of
nico playing guitar
after they watch the video the tv starts
broadcasting the live news that was
taking place when nico was making his
video
at night they invite eye tour with his
mother to have dinner at their house
they share about the strange events that
they had experienced before
either informs them that the little boy
is his best friend
he additionally reveals the story how
nico could be killed at that time
after dinner david searches for news
about prieto being involved in the
murder case
according to the news he was arrested in
his slaughterhouse before he buried his
wife's body and decided to commit
suicide after being in prison for three
months
by the time everyone falls asleep the tv
turns on by itself and starts
broadcasting the old live news again
vera who is awakened by the sound of the
tv approaches it right away
at the same time in 1989 nico turns on
his video camera
they are connected via the video camera
and the tv
their dimensions are connected through a
time tunnel formed by the storms that
occur simultaneously
vera initially gets shocked because she
can see nico through the tv and finds a
way to interact with him
while they are confused nico hears some
noises coming from his neighbor's house
which is prieto's house vera tries hard
to persuade him not to leave his house
so that he will not be hit by a car on
the road she tells all the things that
will happen to nico if he goes to
prieto's house
starting with the incident tomorrow
morning where lightning will strike
nico's school clock
causing the school's electricity to go
out completely and eventually the school
is closed
the next day nico tells his mother what
had happened last night
when nico arrives at his school he is
astonished that everything vera said
actually happened
in vera's timeline she suddenly wakes up
in the hospital where she works
but it seems like everyone treats her
differently in the operating room
everyone calls her as dr vera and she is
requested to operate on a patient
even though she had stopped being a
doctor since she was pregnant
feeling puzzled she leaves the operating
room and rushes to gloria school
however everyone does not recognize her
daughter not even the teacher
knows her she goes straight to david's
office and explains everything that had
happened
then again he does not understand all
the things she just said
finally vera goes to the police station
to tell everything that happened to
inspector lira
at first she tells eitor's story about
nico being hit by a car because he
witnessed a murder
also about nico's appearance on old tv
and vera had warned him of his impending
death
after the incident she doesn't remember
anything then she wakes up in the
hospital
inspector lira explains that david is
not her husband and that gloria never
existed because her birth certificate
and photo were never found
according to him vera is having
hallucinations
he advises vera to do a brain
examination the result is that her brain
is not problematic and in good condition
then the doctor shows her office full of
award certificates which turns out that
she is the best neurologist in the
hospital
since then she just realizes that her
future had changed when she saved nico
from his death
back in the past nico who has been saved
from his death is still curious about
prieto's unusual activities
he sneaks back to prieto's house until
he is so shocked that he finds mrs
vice's body in the bathtub
he wants to run away directly from the
house but at the same time prieto is
back home
nico decides to hide under a bed and he
finds a watch engraved with a letter cm
on the back
he sees prieto carrying a chainsaw to
mutilate mrs vice's body
while he waits for the right time to
escape from the house
in the present vera finds a fictional
book called mirage by karen sardone
then she and inspector lira go to the
library to read the book
it contains the name of nico lazarte
with this evidence
she convinces inspector lira to visit
karen sardon
at last they meet with karen to ask
about niko's whereabouts
karen tells them that she only heard his
mother's story about nico's imagination
being able to communicate with a woman
from the future through the television
they learn that during the current storm
they can communicate with nico and try
to change things
inspector lira tries to help her out but
he needs some proof in order to trust
her
as proof vera tells him to dig and look
for the body of mrs weiss beneath prieto
slaughterhouse
they do so and find a human skeleton in
a suitcase
afterwards inspector lira helps vera by
giving her some credit card information
about nico and an address
when she visits this address she is
shocked to find david cheating on his
wife with a nurse who is vera's friend
she blackmails david who is a bank
employee to get information about nico's
location
in the meantime the police arrest prieto
who is now living with victor and clara
during the interrogation it is also
revealed that prieto and clara were
having an affair and they were caught by
mrs weiss
which led to a fight in which clara
accidentally stabbed weiss
inspector lira asks for the watch clara
is wearing at the time
sure enough there is letter c m on the
back of the watch which means clara
medina
this is in accordance with the statement
of little nico who had reported prieto
to the police
but at that time the police ignored his
report even nico was considered to have
a mental disorder
day by day he became more and more
obsessed with the woman from the future
he only had one clue the valpanieta
station where he hoped to meet the woman
someday
at the end he managed to meet veer at
the station when he had grown up
when veera arrives at nico's place she
is surprised to learn that inspector
lira is nicolazarte
who is in a relationship with her in
this reality lira tells her how he had
waited for her for years and in doing so
had unknowingly prevented her from
meeting david and either veer asks him
to fix the events using the old tv set
and video recorder
then she commits suicide so that lira
will have to save her
leary uses the old tv and video recorder
to communicate with his childhood self
vera wakes up to an earlier version of
reality where david is her husband and
gloria is her daughter
she finds out that david is still
cheating on her she calls the police to
report mrs vice's body beneath the
slaughterhouse
at that place she meets inspector lira
hoping in her new life to start a new
relationship with him along with her
daughter
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching